[MUSIC PLAYING]
MICHAEL HEBB: Welcome
to Death over Dinner.
You might be asking yourself,
what could death and dinner
possibly have in common?
Or maybe you're wondering
why someone would even
want to talk about death,
especially over an otherwise
pleasant supper.
Well, here's the deal.
The way we die in
America, and now
in many other parts of the
world, is pretty messed up--
not just the fact that we die.
End-of-life care
is far from ideal.
And it causes a lot
of bankruptcies.
Most people die in hospitals,
and they're really expensive.
Yet 75% of America says
they want to die at home.
And only 25% of us do.
Regardless of where we spend our
last weeks, days, or moments,
the thing we are
really missing is
a straight-forward conversation.
It's obvious if
you think about it.
If you don't tell
your loved ones
what you want during your
last mile, you won't get it.
Say, for example, you
wanted a vacation in Aruba.
But you didn't tell anyone.
And your well-meaning
family booked you a long,
costly ticket to Antarctica--
not what you wanted.
The default when
it comes to dying
is also very expensive and,
like Antarctica, most likely
not what you wanted.
Not telling your loved
ones what you want only
makes everything a lot harder
for everyone emotionally
and logistically.
They're already going to be
devastated by losing you.
On top of that,
imagine having to make
a seemingly endless
list of decisions
and to make them immediately
during your grief.
So we came up with
a simple solution--
dinner and conversation,
just talking to each other
openly, directly, authentically.
Since we launched, there have
been over 100,000 dinners
in 30 countries.
It seems these two things
go together quite nicely.
So what happens
at a death dinner?
It all begins with our website.
You tell us why you're
interested in having a dinner.
And when you select
an intention,
we magically create a
script for your evening.
In this script, you will find a
series of thoughtful questions
for everyone who comes to
dinner to consider an answer.
If you don't like a particular
question, don't answer it.
And that's about it.
But here are a few pointers.
Don't surprise people.
Pizza night-- surprise!
Death dinner.
No.
Don't hog the talking stick.
Put that phone away.
No one needs you to be
checking your Instagram
while they are talking about
how they want to be remembered.
Make something simple.
Light some candles.
Create the right ambiance.
Give yourself plenty of time.
Make I statements.
This is not an
opportunity to argue.
There are no experts in death.
Listen deeply.
Say something you're
afraid to say.
It is the quickest way to
get closer to the people
in your life.
When you're done, maybe you
want to take some next steps
and put a few things in writing.
Our goal is to change the way we
die one conversation at a time.
Join us.
DAVID LEVIN: Well,
please join me
in giving Michael Hebb
a warm welcome as he
talks about his book "Let's
Talk about Death over Dinner"
[APPLAUSE]
MICHAEL HEBB: Hey, everybody.
Thanks for coming out.
DAVID LEVIN: So I'd like to
talk about just breaking down
the title of the book because I
think you put a bit of thought
into it.
First of all, why dinner?
MICHAEL HEBB: Why dinner?
Well, that's going to--
do you mind if I do a
little tangential answer?
So my background is
actually as a designer.
And I studied architecture.
And I started by--
my interest in
architecture wasn't so much
because I was
fascinated by buildings
and the formal
architecture and wanted
to create something
of great beauty.
But I was really inspired by
how to craft, how to design,
how to shape human experience.
And at the time when I went
to school 20 years ago,
UX wasn't a thing
that we talked about.
If you were interested in
creating human experience,
architecture was one of the
more obvious places to go.
And so I became really
interested in how
you create buildings, gathering
places that would really
have a transformative
effect on the people who
came into these buildings.
And so I spent a
bit of time creating
some guerrilla
architecture, which
we can go into if we want.
My first project-- actually,
an architecture firm that we
created--
a lot of the work
we did was illegal.
And we started a project called
City Repair because we decided
we wanted to repair the city--
it was Portland, Oregon--
in the way that we saw fit,
not necessarily the way
that the city saw that
it needed to be repaired.
And so we started doing things.
And again, we're going to
maybe just put a pin in this
and come back to it if
there's interest around it.
But we started intervening
in the city in the ways
the city got really
pissed off at.
And we were breaking the law.
And through that, though--
and a lot of these
early interventions
were about creating spaces for
people to gather and connect.
That was our focus of the UX.
How do we get people
to create space
where they have an authentic
connection, gathering,
and experience?
And so eventually, after
several years of iterating,
I realized that
architecture is very--
it's a very costly, inefficient
way to create experience.
Obviously, code has become a
much cheaper, more accessible
way to create experience.
It resides on very expensive--
less and less so--
devices.
But nonetheless, it seemed
very unwieldy to have
to go and raise money or
have a client that you happen
to either be aligned
with or not aligned
with who wants to create a thing
so that somebody could have
an experience in the physical
space that would impact them
emotionally, spiritually.
And then I realized
that the dinner table
is readily available and
readily underutilized.
Most people don't
know why they have
a dinner table in their house.
It's one of those almost
leftover functionalities.
What is this?
Is this for mail?
Is it for my kids
to do homework on?
Because 20% of
meals in the United
States are eaten in the car.
And now you add to
that, how many meals
are eaten at the desk?
How many meals are eaten
on a couch in front of TV?
Or more likely,
the larger number
now is in bed with Netflix.
And so you start
to see that here
is this thing, this
object, that most of us
have in some
iteration or another.
And it's not getting used.
And it happens to be in many
ways the first architecture.
So if we go way back,
shelter was almost a given.
We found ways to stay
safe and have shelter.
The fact that at
some point we decided
to create a space to share
food and to share culture
and built this thing, whether
it was low to the ground
or at the height that
we tend to use now,
is a pretty remarkable jump
in the human experience.
It also corresponds, to
some extent, with the fact
that cooking is what,
in fact, made us human.
So Darwin got a lot of things
right as far as we know so far.
He apparently didn't get
the leap from the ape
to man, the missing link, right.
Richard Wrangham is one
of the lead biologists
and evolutionary
biologists at Harvard.
And he's kind of disproved
Darwin's missing link
argument, which
was that we started
to eat very large mammals.
And so we started hunting for
larger and larger mammals.
We had a wealth of protein.
And all of sudden, we made this
transformation from ape to man.
So Wrangham has gone back
through and proven to--
as far as we know for
now, it's actually
the concentration of calories,
which happens when you cook.
So apes have big bellies, really
big jaws, and small brains.
And they chew seven hours a day.
We chew 24 minutes
a day on average.
And that's because we outsourced
all of this huge belly.
Because if you're eating roots
and hard-to-digest things--
a cow has four bellies, right?
So apes have these big bellies.
And then all of a sudden, the
innovation of cooking over fire
to concentrate calories and
make calories more readily
digestible--
a few things happen.
The belly gets smaller.
There's a bunch of new energy,
a new energy source that's
available in the body.
Where is that going to go?
And then the jaw, because
we're not chewing all the time,
thins.
So you have a natural situation
where there's an opening.
It's available for rent.
Space shows up in our heads.
And it gets filled with
much larger brains.
And then you have the advent of
language and-- human language.
I think that apes probably have
a very sophisticated language.
And all of this happens around
the same time, most likely,
that we're eating
together at tables.
And so for me as a
designer, I was like, well,
I don't have to go
and build something.
I can use what's already
there, again, like code.
It's just sitting there.
It's pretty much free.
People have forgotten
how to use it.
And so I can start
to use the table
in really imaginative ways.
And so that's kind of
how the table side of it
came into place.
And I've been having dinners
for the last 25 years
around every topic imaginable.
DAVID LEVIN: So
you had this idea
of having the dinner
around a table,
bringing people together,
getting them out of their beds
from watching Netflix.
And you decide a great way
to do this is bring them
on the cheery topic of death.
Why death?
[LAUGHTER]
MICHAEL HEBB: So
I didn't start off
with such a, quote unquote,
"morbid" centerpiece.
At first I was just interested
in getting people back
to the table and
making it joyful.
And I started a
project in Portland
called Family Supper with
my then-partner Naomi
Pomeroy, which at the
time was considered
the first pop-up
restaurant supper
club of this new
generation of supper clubs.
And so we start inviting
people to our living room,
turned our living room
into a 21-foot table
that I could put
together quickly
and while still
wearing my daughter
in a Baby Bjorn,
which was really
a big part of the
design model of it.
It was like, what
can we do and still
have August in the carrier?
And so the table had to be
very easy to put together,
made of hollow core doors.
We invited people over.
We didn't have any money,
so we couldn't buy chairs.
So the first was,
dinner is free,
but you have to bring
a chair and leave it.
And then we were
like, next one we're
going to have you bring
plates and leave it.
But then the aesthetic
part of my brain
was like, I could deal
with mismatched chairs.
But I couldn't deal
with mismatched china.
and I was like, Ikea just
opened up in Portland.
Hold on the plates.
So the first dinners
were just joyful.
And I got to see the incredible
connection that was happening.
And Portland was
having a real moment.
It's kind of the moment that
led to the now "Portlandia"
that we all know and some love.
But The Decemberists
were just starting
and having their first shows
at some of these dinners and.
Gus Van Sant would show up.
And Miranda July
was at the table.
You had this real
incredible collaboration
and coming together of
brilliant thinkers in Portland
at these dinners
we were throwing.
And that felt good
for a little while.
And then I got really
inspired by the work
of Gore Vidal, who was
one of the great thinkers
of the last 50 years.
And he challenged me to
think about these dinners
as being a modern symposium,
in a sense going back
to the dinners that Socrates
and Plato and Aristotle
and many of the leaders in
the classical period in Athens
hosted, which on one hand
looked like dinner parties.
On the other hand, they
gave us the justice system
and democracy.
And a lot of the most
powerful ideas we have
came from these dinners
within the classical period.
And so the idea was, what
can a dinner conversation do?
How deep can it go?
How much can it impact culture?
So I went from this
idea of just inviting
people back to the
table to seeing,
how much impact can we have?
And how far can you
take the conversations?
What terrain?
What's off limits?
What's taboo?
What's really impactful?
And so I started having
really disruptive or difficult
conversations--
homelessness, wealth
equity, and bringing the 1%
together to talk
about wealth inequity.
I did a dinner with
the president of Rwanda
and the former president
of Ireland, Mary Robinson,
to talk about ending
genocide at the same time
that Kagame, the
president of Rwanda,
was being labeled and
called out as a genocidier,
as an agent of
genocide, himself.
And I decided that we were just
going to invite him to a dinner
to talk about what it would
look like ending genocide
in our lifetime.
What if there was no more
genocide on this planet?
How would we get there?
Maybe he's an expert.
From what side depends on--
but let's just ask him.
And so he did that with
the Clinton Foundation.
And it turned out that three
years after the dinner, Mary
Robinson and Kagame are working
together now all of the time.
She's the chancellor
of the Great Lakes
region of Eastern Africa.
And so a dinner conversation--
if it's potent enough
and it's brave enough--
can actually create a
deep enough relationship.
The beginning of
their relationship
happened at that dinner.
And I don't know all of
the in-between steps.
But to see it many years later--
so I kind of got that an
individual dinner in itself
can change the shape of things.
But I also learned
that the more difficult
the topic matter,
the more vulnerable
it pushed people into, the
more vulnerable the terrain,
the more they got to know
themselves at the table.
People surprised themselves.
I saw it happen.
And it's really lovely to be
in the presence of someone
surprising themselves.
It's one thing when
people are just repeating
that ongoing loop of things.
You know when you're going
about to go on a date
or see a friend,
and you're like,
I'm going to tell
them about this.
And then I'm going to
tell them about this.
And you're kind of rehearsing
what you're going to say.
And then you say it.
And it doesn't really
feel that good.
You're like, no, I didn't
really have a real experience.
I started to get interested
in dinners and topics
where people were
like, I just said that.
I've never said that before.
Or their spouse would
be like, I've never
heard-- we've been
together for 30 years,
and you've never
told me this thing.
So that was the area--
I started to see that
the table is really
good at that space of
getting to know ourselves,
connecting people, and where
we surprise ourselves as well.
And death ended up being the
strongest medicine-- this thing
that we avoid so much in our
culture for so many reasons,
some of them very silly.
But the fact that we
have avoided this topic,
bringing it back to
people, and giving it
kind of like a gift,
not a challenge--
not something dark,
but it's a gift
to actually talk about this.
Those were the most powerful
dinners I've ever done.
And then I wanted to
create a digital platform
where everybody can have
that experience, not just
this rarefied group
of individuals.
DAVID LEVIN: So you
talked about how
people have these moments
where they surprise themselves.
Can you tell us a
little bit about how
that happens with
death or where they
talk about death over dinner?
MICHAEL HEBB: Yeah, sure.
So we used to get reminded
about death all the time.
For one, people
would die younger.
They would die
more unexpectedly.
We would see dead bodies.
We would see people dying.
We hadn't overmedicalized death.
Our rituals around death and
dying were more confronting.
Now you almost never see a body.
And it feels almost a
sterilized ritual around--
am I at a funeral?
I couldn't tell.
So there's a lot
of things that have
taken this conversation of
death or this engagement
with our mortality
out of our purview.
And religion likes to
use memento mori as well,
have us coming to terms
with our mortality.
And religion
doesn't play as much
of a role in people's
lives anymore.
So for the whole
of our existence,
we've been in an
ongoing confrontation
with our mortality.
And now we've medicalized
and sterilized and distanced
ourselves from this fact.
In fact, a lot of people
are fascinated, especially
in the tech space, in this
idea of curing or defeating
death, which is fine.
That's not a value statement.
But it's just a
sign of the times
that we're not confronting it.
And so there's such
tremendous opportunity
when you bring this
thing that we all share,
this thing that really
touches one of the most
beautiful places in us.
Because when you
talk about the fact
that you're mortal, that
it eventually will end,
it's not that that needs
to be dark or scary.
That also just will
very quickly put
into perspective what's
most valuable to you,
what your priorities are.
OK.
So it's going to end.
What do I want to
do while I'm here?
Am I operating with
some hidden bias?
We all have biases.
We all have hidden
biases, invisible biases.
Most of us have
biases around the fact
that we're going to die.
So am I operating
within a hidden bias
that doesn't have me deeply
appreciate the limited resource
that life is, how important
the relationships are?
It's kind of grossly animated by
a bucket list, which is great.
But why not every day?
And so when you see
people together delving
into these canyons
that we've determined
are dark but, in fact,
are filled with vitality,
you see them see parts
of themselves they don't
get access to all the time.
And that's why we
educate ourselves.
We educate ourselves
because we get
in touch with parts of ourselves
that we didn't have access
to before we were educated
or we didn't have access
to experiences.
So this kind of enrichment--
there's incredible
information about life
and yourself in the
terrain that is called
death and end of
life, whether you've
been given permission or a
good invitation or somebody
has led you through that in a
way that's exciting to you--
most likely not in our culture.
DAVID LEVIN: We're going
to go on with questions.
But if you have any questions,
just come to the microphone.
As you all come up, I'll
start calling you all in
to join in the conversation.
But real quickly,
I'll bounce off
a topic you just touched on.
You were saying about how
the conversation about death
can lead to, in a way,
clarifying your life somewhat.
What are some questions that
you had that relate to that?
MICHAEL HEBB: Some
questions that I had--
DAVID LEVIN: Or some
questions that you have
that people could talk about.
MICHAEL HEBB: Yeah, absolutely.
So what happens
at a death dinner,
as people are very curious.
They want to have
a preview of it
before they jump
in for that swim.
And I think that the
book actually gives you
a pretty good experience without
having to be at a dinner.
But one such question that is
more deep end of the pool is--
I ask people frequently
at these dinners,
let's imagine that you only
have 30 days left to live.
What is your immediate emotion?
You can't change the prognosis.
You can't change the fact that
you're going to die in 30 days.
Are you angry?
Are you strangely peaceful?
Are you nervous?
Are you anxious?
And then how are you going
to spend the next 30 days?
What are you going to do?
Are you the type of
person that's like,
I'm going to go to the
Seven Wonders of the World?
Or some people--
I'm going to do precisely what
I'm already doing every day.
I wouldn't change a thing.
Or, I'm going to write
letters to my children
or my grandchildren or
whatever for posterity.
Maybe you think that everybody
wants to have letters from you.
And what are the
things that you value
when you think that you
have such a limited time?
What does your
last day look like?
What does your last
hour look like?
Who's around you?
How are you feeling?
There's not a lot
of people asking you
this question in modern
life that we're living.
And when you see someone
go through those emotions
and encounter and confront
this, quote unquote,
"grim reaper," you really
get down to the core of them.
You can't really hide
from that question.
And people will-- if they don't
want to answer, they don't.
But I've actually never had a
situation where someone doesn't
want to freely walk
into that space
and get to know themselves.
So they may walk away.
And they're like, I
need to have children.
I didn't think that I was
going to have children.
And I had this death dinner.
And now I know I need
to have children.
Or, I'd never thought that I
could take care of even a dog.
But now I'm going to get a dog.
One of the other questions is--
you're in a major earthquake.
You know you're not
going to make it out.
If you had one
phone call to make,
if you had this little window
and you had one phone call,
is it an apology?
Is it a regret?
Is there something--
who would you
call if you had one call left?
And what would you say?
And why haven't you said it yet?
There's a lot.
We could spend a couple
hours psychologically just
unpacking that basic question.
And your therapist probably
isn't going to ask you this.
It would be a little bit
intense if you lay down
on your therapist's couch and
they start asking the questions
that I ask.
You might not see
that therapist again.
But we've created the
blameable third party.
Imagine if your
therapist also wanted you
to play Cards Against humanity.
You'd be like, uh-uh.
You should have
your license pulled.
So there's this thing where
if we create a death dinner
and it becomes this trend like
a board game, and it's fun,
and you can step into it,
and you can blame us--
I don't know.
The script's right here.
Cards Against Humanity wants
me to say this thing aloud.
I guess I will.
So we become a
blameable third party
so that you can have
a deep experience
and connect with the
people in your life.
And there's a bunch
of practical reasons
why you want to know these
things about yourself.
You want to know them
about your loved ones.
You want them to
know what you want.
Because if they don't know
it, it's not going to happen.
DAVID LEVIN: So we
have a question.
MICHAEL HEBB: Yeah, of course.
AUDIENCE: What do you think
caused under-utilization
of the dinner table over time?
MICHAEL HEBB: The what?
AUDIENCE: The under-utilization
of the dinner table.
MICHAEL HEBB: The
under-utilization?
DAVID LEVIN: Of the
dinner table, yeah.
MICHAEL HEBB: Yeah.
I think a lot of things
led to us not knowing
how to eat together.
The glorification of mass
produced and industrialized
food.
The science of food.
How exciting it was to
move from the albatross
to being almost like
a beast of burden that
had to cook, that that was a
lowly thing that you would have
to grow your own food
and then have to cook it,
this miraculous thing that
it's in a can, some sort
of plastic packaging that, in
fact, will kill us we found.
The fact that we glorified
convenience and technology
without thinking about
what makes us human,
what gives us joy.
If we're connected to
where food is grown,
we have much more gratitude.
We're also getting much
higher nutrients, especially
if we're building soil.
And then if we're learning
how to prepare that food,
the fact is the food is going to
have much more nutrient value.
Because if somebody you love
is cooking it for somebody else
you love, more
likely that you're
going to sit down and share
that food over a conversation
because somebody has
invested time and energy.
Whereas if I just pick up
Uber Eats and order something,
it doesn't really
feel like an insult
to sit down with the
next episode of "Narcos"
or whatever, which
I'm totally down with.
I did that last night.
But we're living
in a culture where
I believe that antidepressants
are the most prescribed pill
in the United States.
So why?
Why are we depressed?
We're looking for meaning.
Where can we inject more meaning
or lean in towards more meaning
or create more
meaning in our lives?
One thing for sure is knowing
where our food comes from,
having a meaningful
relationship to how it's grown
and how we prepare it
and how we serve it,
and then connecting with other
humans in our lives over it
has worked for a long
time for humankind.
So I think that it's a little
bit like the opposite of--
what's the inverse
of an exponential?
AUDIENCE: Logarithmic.
MICHAEL HEBB: Logarithmic?
OK, see?
I'm glad I'm here.
So there's like a logarithmic
relationship to forgetting
these type of skills.
And they're really hard.
It would be hard to have
them grow, once again,
because a few generations
in of not knowing
the importance of
sitting at a table
together or cooking
our food together
or having meaningful
conversations over that table--
it's almost completely gone.
It becomes a relic.
DAVID LEVIN: Yeah.
I think we have
another question.
MICHAEL HEBB: Yeah, of course.
AUDIENCE: So if I want to
talk about death over dinner,
who should I invite
to the dinner?
And have you noticed
different responses, say,
if I'm with some of my friends
versus my family, parents,
children, spouse?
Are there different themes
that come up or [INAUDIBLE]??
MICHAEL HEBB: Totally.
Yeah.
So who should you
invite to dinner?
Well, in the video, the idea
is you don't surprise people.
There is a great process
of self-selection
around this conversation
and these dinners.
Some people aren't ready.
You might be like, I tried
to talk to my spouse.
And she or he says no.
My parents absolutely
are not into it.
My friends seem like
they're more willing.
So let me start there.
The thing is, you will
have a completely different
conversation with your friends
than you will with your spouse
than you will with your parents
than you will with your kids
if you have them.
And each one of them are
valuable for different reasons.
Your friends is
really about getting
to know each other better and
connecting with your friends.
You'll get a profound
connection with whoever you
sit down at this table with.
I've seen complete
strangers become
lifelong friends in three
hours because the topic is
so unusual.
So the other thing to know about
when you're inviting somebody
and it seems like they're
not interested in having
this conversation--
you're in this room.
You have some interest
in this conversation.
But maybe the people
around you in your life
don't have as much interest.
And it seems like they don't
want to talk to you about it
if you've tried.
So the thing about
this conversation
is we're not good at rejection.
Sometimes I say if
we were as good at--
how does it go?
If we looked at it like
courtship and getting a job
and we treated death
conversation the same
as we treat those things,
we would never find love.
And we'd never get a job
because those things take
all our creativity and
tenacity to have happen.
You're in this room
because you're tenacious.
Because you're on this campus,
you've got a job at Google
because you've probably
had a bunch of rejections
along the way to get here.
And you've just persevered.
Now, if you want to know
how the people in your life
want to be remembered,
what they want
have to happen to their
body, all of these things--
what they want their
last days to look
like-- you can find it out.
The trick is, it's
not about them.
They won't talk because
everybody who is alive
is having a conversation in
their head about the fact
that they're going to die.
Everybody knows it.
They got the press release.
Completely clear.
Now, there might be
certain layers of denial.
Or they don't want to
talk to you about it.
And so instead of
being like, they
don't want to talk
about it-- no,
they don't want to
talk to me about it.
So how do I have to
shift my way of being
so that the people
in my life want
to talk to me about this thing
that's so important to them?
And so it shifts from
this blaming mentality
that we usually
have-- people have
around parents, especially.
I get it.
They're triggering.
Or spouses-- I get
it, also triggering.
But they do have a conversation.
How do you get invited into it?
I mean, if you want
to try out a dinner,
send an invite
out to 20 friends.
You'll probably get
five or so that'll bite.
Maybe you'll get none.
And maybe you'll be
like, I need new friends.
I'm sure they're fine.
But the other thing
is, just go gently.
The culture is changing
around this topic.
There's a lot of people
doing amazing work.
And so the literacy level
about end of life and dying
is literally rising
up every day.
The system is getting
more and more intelligent
and connected and acceptable.
When we started this
seven years ago,
there were no articles
about death and dying.
Once a month there
might be a minor piece.
If we did a search right now
about death and dying and then
looked at it-- you guys
could do this pretty easily--
looked at it historically
about the amount of pure media
and the amount of
front-page news
all across the world right
now, we have a sea change.
And there's a lot of people
doing incredible work.
So when you're inviting
people into the conversation,
you're inviting them into a
higher and higher literacy
rate.
And so that's why
I do this work-- is
to increase the literacy.
Literacy increases empowerment.
When people feel empowered,
they make decisions
that more are aligned
with their true selves.
People are happier.
The world's happier,
environment's
better, all of these things.
So that's kind of
how I break it down.
DAVID LEVIN: So we mentioned
relatives and friends.
But does it even have to
be with people you know?
I mean, I guess you
have to know them
well enough to invite them.
MICHAEL HEBB: Yeah, no.
I think that you guys could
do death over dinner, death
over lunch here quite easily.
There's a lot of corporations
that do, actually.
And the fact is you will know
the people you sit down with.
You will feel connected to them.
When we created
deathoverdinner.org,
the platform, I knew I
didn't have the bandwidth
to manage a community.
As you sure well
know, the amount
of resource to properly manage
a community and serve them
is tremendous, especially
in digital work and scale.
And so when we created
Death over Dinner,
we built it for $11,000 that
we raised from an Indiegogo
campaign.
And for five years, that was
the only funding we had--
so $11,000.
Civilization, this incredible
design firm in Seattle
who just won the
Cooper Hewitt Award
for design agency of the year--
they pitched in a
bunch of free time.
We built this thing together.
It ran with a $0 annual
budget for five years.
At a conservative count,
there's been over--
this video is old now--
200,000 dinners.
This means a million
people have sat down
and had this conversation
for literally $11,000.
You think about a million
people having a two-
to three-hour experience.
So it worked, this
idea meeting its time.
But we realized
that we didn't have
the resources to engage
a community and say,
here's a dinner happening.
It was all like, hey, if
you want to do a dinner,
just like a board
game, here it is.
It's on you.
Make it happen.
So that was our model,
really, just because
of the lack of resources.
DAVID LEVIN: Yeah.
So you talk about
lack of resources.
In other cases, I
think I've heard
you refer to the website and
its presentation as a gift.
Why is that important to
you that it's like a gift?
MICHAEL HEBB: Yeah.
I mean, there's been
lots of opportunities
to transactionalize it.
People are like, well,
we're going to sell tickets.
We can maybe sell tickets.
Or insurance companies-- do
you want to partner with us?
And what a great way to
sell some life insurance.
Sure.
No.
[LAUGHTER]
The thing about
transactions is that they
don't necessarily,
by their design,
bring people closer together.
That's not the nature
of a transaction.
A transaction
intentionally creates
a little bit of a boundary.
You know what you're
getting for it.
Somebody knows what
they're giving you.
That's great and clear.
Gifts are messier.
They're more human.
Gifts are intended to
obligate people in some way.
Warring tribes would
give each other gifts
as this way of obligation.
Gifts stay in some
level of circulation.
That's kind of just their DNA.
There's a DNA of a gift.
And there's a DNA
of a transaction.
Lewis Hyde writes about
this really brilliantly.
And he was one of the people
who inspired Lessig and the--
what's the open source that
Lawrence Lessig started?
What is it?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
MICHAEL HEBB: No, no.
But he is involved
in that as well.
I was thinking of the commons--
AUDIENCE: Creative Commons.
MICHAEL HEBB: Creative Commons,
yeah, inspired in great part
by Lewis Hyde's work around the
DNA of transaction versus gift.
And I really wanted
this to be really clear
that no one was
enriching themselves,
that people were actually
doing the opposite of enriching
themselves, that they felt
so passionately about this
that they were going to
risk their good name.
When I first came
up with the idea
and called a bunch of friends
in the health care space,
they're like, no.
You're crazy.
It's not going to work.
Everyone's going to
think you're insane.
You can't death and dinner.
And now we're partnering with
the Cleveland Clinic, which
is one of the most
reputable health care
systems in the world.
And they were building
the medical edition
with the Cleveland
Clinic and probably 1,000
medical partners.
And I'm lecturing
at Sloan Kettering
and partnering with
Sloan Kettering.
So in about a
month, we've entered
into the oncology space,
the terminal illness
space, which would not let
you into this conversation.
Death and cancer?
They're just not
in the same room.
We're going to beat cancer.
And I was like, the
elephant is in the room.
People who have a stage four
terminal diagnosis-- they
are thinking about the
fact that they might die.
Let's give them the
opportunity to talk about it.
And I got a big
no for many years.
And now I'm getting,
what a great idea.
Where have you been
our whole lives?
It's like, OK, yes.
It's changing.
But for me to be
able to get access
to work with the Cleveland
Clinic and Sloan Kettering,
it had to be a gift.
If I was an entrepreneur
who had this idea,
we wouldn't be sitting here.
And there wouldn't be a book.
DAVID LEVIN: You talked
about sending that email
to 20 of your friends.
I think at one point you had
this time when you sent out
an email to a lot
of your friends.
It resulted in you attending
your own funeral, I think.
Can you tell us a little
bit more about that?
How did it happen?
MICHAEL HEBB: Yeah.
Careful what you ask for.
So I had just broken up with the
love of my life, so I thought.
And I was really depressed.
And I was about to turn 40.
And the first thing
I thought was,
I'm going to be alone
on my 40th birthday.
And here's this great reckoning.
And I'm going to think
about what a failure I
am romantically.
And I'm going to be alone.
And so I sent out an
email to about 50 friends
saying, hey, in two
months I'm turning 40.
I don't know where
we're going to be.
But I'm going to be somewhere
in the northern coast
of California.
Save the date.
Tell me if you can come now.
I need to know.
And I got 40 yeses.
I'll be there.
Immediately I was
like, whew, I'm not
going to be alone on my 40th.
And then about a week
later, a friend--
because now there's this list
with all of these people on it.
Even though I was like, don't
reply all, he breaks that rule
and says, hey, so Mr.
Death is turning 40.
Let's go ahead and
celebrate his great turn
by throwing him
a living funeral.
And at that point, somebody has
called out an amazing challenge
to me in front of everybody.
And I can't be like,
that's a terrible idea.
I actually was broken hearted.
That's why I'm doing this.
And now I have to die.
And so I was like, great.
Yes.
Yeah, of course.
We'll do it.
And it got really serious.
It really built up
steam as it got closer.
And it turned into
the centerpiece
of this long weekend and a whole
day dedicated to preparations.
I ended up being
ritually bathed,
anointed with oils,
dressed in white,
brought downstairs
with my eyes closed.
I actually was blindfolded
downstairs into this courtyard.
And before I know
it, I'm being helped
into what I then
realized just by texture
and smell was my own
coffin and then picked up
by pallbearers whose breath
smelled like whiskey.
It's funny-- the little details,
the whiskey on their breath.
I was like, I'm definitely at
my own funeral slash Irish wake.
And they're drinking
because they're
having a really hard time.
They're not drinking because
they're day drinkers.
They're drinking
because they're dealing
with what looks like one
of their best friend's
bodies in a coffin.
And the whole thing makes
them incredibly uncomfortable.
And so I get lifted
into this darkened room.
It has one candle.
And there's like
40 people in it.
And a friend of mine--
I didn't know who
it was at the time
because I couldn't
recognize by her wailing--
starts losing it in the way
that you might pay somebody
to cry at your funeral--
[? keeners, ?] which is still
a thing all over the world.
You can pay someone to cry.
And what it helps is other
people have the emotion.
But I wasn't paying her.
And she couldn't control it.
And it was this
incredible woman, Alex,
who just started wailing,
sobbing uncontrollably.
And then it was very clear
that this was not a joke.
Anybody who was still
kind of tongue in cheek--
I mean, there might have
been some people there that
had ingested some psilocybin.
But that probably just made
it even more intense for them.
I wasn't ingesting psilocybin
that day, just so we're clear.
And so I'm laying
in this coffin.
And for three hours, my
friends air their grievances--
real grievances--
as if I were dead.
I was like, I can hear you--
really where I had failed them.
But then the harder part
was where they loved me.
I got to hear this.
And I couldn't do
anything about it--
40 people that mean the most to
in your life feeling like they
can tell you in an unabashed
way how they feel about you
without you being
able to deflect it,
without you being able to
acknowledge them, nothing.
I couldn't take it.
And it made me
really uncomfortable.
And my 15-year-old
daughter was there.
And she got up on
the edge of my coffin
and started talking to me.
You want to have an
emotional experience?
Have your 15-year-old daughter
attend your own funeral
while you're awake.
And so ultimately, my
takeaways from it--
and so we created this
whole site, The Living Wake,
so that people, again, can
have a blameable resource
to throw these things.
Because a lot of people--
they're 80 or 90, or they
just want to play Tom Sawyer--
want to have these experiences.
But they don't want to be
the person that comes up
with the idea and organizes it.
So livewake.com we produced
just for, again, a gift.
But what I realized
from that experience
is I don't know how
to receive love.
I got really good at giving it.
And then I also in
research about how we die--
there is an incredible
book called "How We Die."
And I learned that the
heart is essentially
two muscles on a timer.
It's two distinct organs.
One of those organs
receives blood.
It's what it does all
day, receiving blood,
oxygenating it.
And then the other half of
our heart distributes blood.
That's all it does.
It just pumps blood all day.
And then the timer--
so you get pump pump, pump pump.
Receive, give, receive,
give, receive, give.
And a heart attack,
which is still
the number-one
killer in the world,
is an imbalance between
give and receive.
It's an imbalance in that heart.
The timing is off.
And I was like, OK, so
if I don't figure out
this side of my heart
that's receiving,
then I'm reducing my
lifespan, reducing
how much I can actually give if
I don't learn how to receive.
And I'm going to die sooner.
And so I got it
really hard that I
needed to learn how to
slow down and receive,
a pretty good lesson.
DAVID LEVIN: You have
a ritual that you
begin these things
with and a ritual
that you end them with as well.
At the end, I think you
have a ritual that everybody
says something that they really
appreciate about the person
to the side of them.
And so I guess I'll end.
And I'll say something that
I appreciate about you.
Thank you so much for
coming here to talk to us.
And thank you for covering
this important topic,
spending the time to think about
important questions that can
help us learn more about life.
You have a quote in the
book from Kyoko Mori
that says, "everything
we say about death
is actually about life."
And I feel like the questions
you have in here really
help us to think about
our life and think
about what's important.
Thank you very much
for coming here today.
MICHAEL HEBB: Yeah.
It's an honor to be here.
[APPLAUSE]